et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
patrick kanner bonjour mr bonjour avec
nous sénateur du nord président du
groupe socialiste is you sénat on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern et bonjour stéphane
bonjour stéphane qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france
on va parler des régionales des suites
des régionales et de cette interview
d'emmanuel mâcon dans le magazine elle
patrick kanner emmanuel macron qui dit
qu'il ne changera pas de premier
ministre est-ce qu'il a raison de ne pas
tirer des leçons nationales d'un scrutin
local
si j'étais facétieux je dirais on ne
change pas une équipe qui perd mais bon
voilà c'est son choix il en est
responsable
c'est une forme curieuse quand même
parce que quand on a un tel échec après
les municipales un tel échec après les
départementales et régionales
on devrait se poser des questions mais
je pense que le président public est
pétri de certitudes bondir qu'il aurait
fallu un remaniement pour vous écouter
il aurait fallu un changement de premier
ministre au ministre peut-être pas mais
on avait annoncé des changements à la
marge
bon il ya quand même des ministres
quinze ministres qui ont été au combat
certains ont réussi à passer la barre du
premier tour très peu très peu et
d'ailleurs dans votre région qui n'ont
pas passé la barre du traitement
donc d'eads avec un score extrêmement
médiocre bon dans ces cas là on peut
imaginer
enfin moi j'ai lu nouveau du vieux monde
pardon et je me souviens qu'en 2015
quand ils me suis présenté aux élections
départementales
françois hollande avait dit à ses
ministres qu'ils présentaient bon voila
si bouvier et si vous perdez il ya une
règle non écrite mais qui fait que quand
on perd
et quand on est ministre eh bien on se
retire ce qui semble assez normal voilà
mes démissionner en tout cas n'était pas
tête de liste mais dont il a démissionné
je ne tire pas sur les ambulances
je ne tiens pas sur les ambulances le
président de la république a fait cette
déclaration dans dans souvent journal
féminin c'est son droit le plus strict
ils les responsables de la situation
mais c'est vrai que ce gouvernement est
pléthorique pléthorique
très honnêtement parfois il nous arrive
de nous demander côté sénateur ben temps
c'est qui cette personne là enfin on
oublie non voilà je le dis sans aucune
animosité mais parce que c'est vrai que
avec la crise sanitaire
il n'y a que quelques ministres qui ont
pu sortir du lot les autres sont passés
dans une forme d'oubli généralisé avant
l'heure donc c'est un peu dur ce que je
vous dis là mais un gouvernement
resserré pour terminer le quinquennat
n'aurait pas été un scandale
d'une manière générale est ce que
président la république a raison de
faire comme si de rien n'était a
sûrement pas il faut qu'il s'exprime et
doit prendre la parole routes romandes
dans l as je je je regrette qu'il n'y
ait pas une expression concrète c'est un
grave échec pour la majorité
présidentielle qui a commencé avec les
élections municipales
aucune grande ville aucune ville moyenne
détenue par la majorité municipale sauf
quelques villes anciennes détenues par
le modem par exemple qui manquent de la
majorité mais qui n'est pas public en
marche
aucun département aucune région fut sera
présidé par un représentant de la
majorité présidentielle ça veut dire que
la macro ni n'a pas réussi son
implantation territoriale qu'aujourd'hui
tout repose sur les épaules d'un seul
homme c'est assez extraordinaire à dire
la macro ni finalement c'est emmanuel
macron ces macro emmanuel un bulletin
dans tous les sens et on voit bien que
l'avenir de la macro ni en 2022
éventuellement passe par
l'investissement personnel
stricto sensu d' emmanuel macron g7 type
métaphore que j'utilise souvent en 2017
la pyramide macron reposer sur sa base
aujourd'hui elle repose sur sa pointe
elle est toujours en équilibre mais elle
peut basculer très très facilement le
est ce que leur asthme au national n'a
pas exactement le même problème une
seule personne oui on l'a on l'a
peut-être vu dimanche dernier
ses interprétations que notamment là
aussi raté les municipales l'année
dernière j'en rate et ils ont quelques
villes et aux gardes et quelques villes
ils n'ont pas pu prendre de départements
et de régions et je m'en félicite
en tant que tel cela repose sur marine
le pen alors par assimilation je
pourrais vous dire ma finalement le duel
mc ren le pen le pen macron n'est
peut-être pas si évident que cela a nui
travailler à la droite de trouver son
champion sur l'incarnation son projet à
la gauche aussi de trouver son projet
sur la création sa stratégie électorale
et peut-être qu'on pourra éviter ce duel
qui moi m'a inquiète beaucoup parce
qu'aujourd'hui même le pen est en
difficulté avec son parti mais
l'électorat est toujours là il fait
moins mobilisée cette fois ci n'en
tirons pas des conséquences immédiates
juste on va revenir sur les conséquences
pour la gauche et sur la mobilisation et
un bon puisque vous dites qu emmanuel
macron doit s'exprimer de s'exprimer
comment est ce que par exemple il doit
réunir les parlementaires en congrès
pour vous il s'était engagé à le faire
j'étais en dvg arrive et promis de
livrer tous les ans
donc il s'est arrêté en 2018
sauf erreur de ma part pas de contrainte
19 pas de congrès en 2020 il ya aussi la
crise sanitaire je dire que encore une
fois il faut aussi regarder dans quel
contexte nous sommes ce serait pas
anormal que pour la dernière année du
quinquennat il y eut une expression
publique qui permettent finalement au
président de groupe qui finalement
nantais reçu qu'une seule fois moi j'ai
été reçue je suis présent depuis 2018
avec des gens vis 2018 il a été reçu
qu'une seule fois l'occasion du grand
débat mais je moi j'aimerais que le
président de république de tangente en
voit la rencontre les présidents de
groupe il a vu ses président pendant la
crise sanitaire mais manière collective
manière individuelle jamais ou quasiment
jamais donc oui à un congrès d'ici la
fin de la session extraordinaire la
démocratie a besoin de rendez vous vous
parlez de mobilisation l'un des
enseignements de ce scrutin c'est
l'abstention est toujours dans le
magazine elle emmanuel macron il
explique par le fait je cite que ces
élections sont arrivés à un moment ce
n'était pas le rythme du pays force est
de constater que les gens n'avaient pas
du tout la tête à cela
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
explication ça c'est quand même très
léger comme explication vire ses
vraquiers pas une mobilisation on pourra
y revenir mais prendre dix minutes ou un
quart de son temps même pendant les
années folles de sortie de crise
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas impossible non
c'est trop facile c'est trop facile de
dire ça ça montre qu'il va enjamber ces
élections et surtout les résultats de
ces élections les français ont eu bien
d'autres raisons d'ailleurs je pense
qu'il faudra bien étudiée sérieusement
pour démontrer qu en fait le principal
pour vous c'est quoi alors il ya des
régions de trois principales
je commence par la raison technique
keynes qui n'est pas la principale mais
la raison technique de la non
distribution à des millions de français
dépression deux fois premier au second
tour est un vrai scandale n'ont pas
d'état mais un scandale quand même pour
la démocratie française et pour la
cinquième réunion n'est d'accord c'est
par là principe non je n'ai pas la page
c'est pas la principale l'offre
politique a été perturbé je pense que la
concomitance des deux élections est un
élément de perturbation de confiance
était trop compliqué de lui d'avoir
mélangé il faut s'organiser d'avoir mes
données géante vous avez tendu l'oreille
moi aussi quand je vois ce jeudi avec un
peu de tristesse la faiblesse de la
compréhension du rôle des départements
des les régions cette confusion générale
bon la concomitance n'est pas un élément
de clarification delà de la présentation
des candidats vous savez moi je les
bienvenus dans mon département
les candidats dans le nord on était un
peu écrasée par la campagne régionale
qui a été très nationaliser n'ont pas pu
vraiment s'exprimer
je regrette parce que il ya eu de beaux
combats départementaux qui n'ont pas pu
aller jusqu'au bout parce que finalement
il y a eu cette concomitance
et puis mais la principale raison c'est
la manière dont les français considère
qu'aujourd'hui la politique peut changer
leur vie et là il ya un vrai sujet est
quelque part cette abstention c'est
d'abord de l'abstention sur le bilan de
monsieur macron ils n'ont pas changé
leur vie c'est parce qu'il dit toujours
dans l eurasie l'abstention n'est pas
une fatalité la seule élection dans
laquelle je me suis engagé depuis que je
suis président c'est l'élection
européenne
or on n'a jamais autant voter pour ce
scrutin oui c'est vrai c'était un
scrutin nationalisée absolument avec un
taux de participation qui était assez
étonnant on n'était pas non plus dans la
crise son engagement
dans une campagne majeure on voit bien
que allume amis seul emmanuel macron est
capable non pas de renverser la table
mais peut-être de renverser une tendance
la force de la crise et macron chacun
chacun le sait bien
néanmoins cette fois ci à une échéance
qui concernent la vie quotidienne des
gens donc il n'est pas un élément de
politique générale
finalement les élections européennes
était la réplique de l'élection
présidentielle avec une gauche une
gauche très faible et disons le très
très clairement à ces élections
départementales et régionales les
français pouvaient choisir finalement
comment ils allaient vivre dans le cas
des compétences de ces deux
collectivités
ils ne sont pas bouger parce qu'ils
n'ont pas cru et donc derrière cela
c'est de notre parole qui est en cause
il faut le dire que comment convaincre
les gens d'aller d'aller voter
quand les choses marchent bien au niveau
technique c'est aussi important et on
pourra y revenir
deuxièmement je considère que
aujourd'hui on a manifestement de la
part des français un doute dans cette
capacité à changer leur vie et surtout
une absence de leur participation il
faut permettre et faut ouvrir la
démocratie française à de nouveaux modes
de participation mais qu est ce qu on va
en parler d'un référendum vous imaginez
aujourd'hui la tenue d'un référendum sur
le climat qui ferait 10 % de deux taux
de participation n'offrait plus parce
que il y aurait une mobilisation
générale
quand nous lisons que les électeurs se
seraient capables de se mobiliser pour
écouter et modifier une from a ajouté
une phrase dans l'article de la
constitution française alors ça ça
mobiliseront quand il y aura un vrai
enjeu
le problème c'est que l'as tout ceci
c'est du bluff quoi aujourd'hui de la
part de divin et mâcon et ce dossier
d'ailleurs à revenir vous le savez au
parlement mais prenons l'exemple de
participation citoyenne que moi j'ai
connu en direct avec le référendum
d'initiative partagée sur
les âges et aéroports de paris adp il ya
un million deux cent mille français qui
ont signé la pétition il en manquait
encore 3 millions je le regrette
naturellement mais un million c'est pas
neutre donc quand on quand on intéresse
les français quand on leur demande leur
avis quand on leur permet de pouvoir
participer à la vie locale les
référendum d'initiative locale
ça existe dans les textes mais ils ne
sont pas appliqués donc l'interprétation
elle est aussi pour nous c'est à dire
comment nous dans notre vie quotidienne
d'europe représentant du peuple
on considère que le peuple n'est pas là
que pour venir voter une fois tous les
cinq ou six ans et notamment c'est
notamment cela c'était le cas aussi ce
dimanche vous avez deux régions il ya
une union de la gauche entre premier et
le deuxième tour il pouvait y avoir une
bascule à la condition d'une
mobilisation d'une sur mobilisation de
l'électorat de gauche qui n'a pas du
tout exister je pense à l'île de france
au pays de la loire il cesser
encéphalogramme plat que vous n'allez
pas c'est l'union n'a pas mobilisé
l'électorat de gauche que je vous
concède que là où voilà je le dis très
directement les verts ont été à la bonne
heure
ça n'a pas créé une plus value disons le
très clairement celle en faut 2 c'est ce
qu'ils ont dit les électeurs de ça veut
dire que quelque part l'électorat
majoritaire à gauche est plutôt un
électorat socialiste/social-démocrate
qui ne sont pas totalement retrouvé y
compris dans des alliances qui peut-être
ont pu les gêner dans mary compris chez
vous jette les cas là est ce que c'était
une erreur de m karima delli liste il
aurait fallu un socialiste alors je moi
j'étais candidat j'aurai préfet mais les
conditions n'ont pas été réunies pour
pouvoir aboutir à ce résultat
est ce que j'aurais pu faire mieux
peut-être ce qui est certain c'est que
une alliance à gauche très large a pu
dans ma région avec notamment la
présence de deux candidats et les filles
mais peut-être que des électeurs et les
filles n'ont pas voulu de socialistes
aussi et n'ont pas été voter donc
l'union et à talisman est-ce que c'est
l'union la plus large possible
il faut s'interroger et c'est vrai que
dans les premiers sondages et vous de
réunir les quatre parties je vais jouer
à l'échelon de mon raisonnement
dans les premiers sondages nous étions à
25% à 4 on tombe à 21,22 pont donc on
est un petit peu en dessous pas beaucoup
en tout mais quand même en dessous mais
si nous l'avions pas fait l'union au
premier tour nous aurions plafonné à 11
12% et il y aurait été très difficile de
créer une dynamique complémentaire donc
je pense qu'on a fait le bon choix
politiques autour de karima delli
mais il est vrai que là où les
socialistes était en pole position
c'est vrai qu'ils aient aussi sortant
nous avons conservé les régions nous
avons gagné des places
là où ce n'était pas un socialiste ça a
été plus difficile ça veut dire
concrètement que dans l'union de la
gauche est dans la perfide de 2022
les électeurs les électeurs pas nous
même pas nous en tant que ps mais les
électeurs ont classé les socialistes
dans une position de leadership s'est
pas encore une fois nous mêmes qui nous
arrosons ce droit où cette
responsabilité les électeurs nous place
dans une position de leadership qui nous
oblige à créer les conditions du
rassemblement donc ça serait le son pour
aller au bout de votre raisonnement pas
très clair le candidat de la gauche à la
présidentielle el-oued socialiste bah je
pense qu'il peut pas y avoir entre les
socialistes et les verts deux candidats
sinon ne feront que témoigner et le
socialiste que je suis pense que la
meilleure solution c'est qu'il y ait un
candidat ou une candidate
en l'occurrence pour ce qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui pour porter les
valeurs de la gauche et de la scène une
écologie ge et valeurs de la gauche
socialiste et de l'écologie une
candidate s'est classé n ouvelle gauvin
candidate - oui clairement il faut
qu'elle ya le camp maintenant c'est ça
c'est l'été c'est cette relation
personnelle entre
un candidat est le peuple français ça se
décide pas 33 40
ainsi tel qu'il décidera mais je sais
c'est faible dans les sondages est ce
qu'elle n'est pas aussi affaibli par son
score le score des régionales en île de
france qui n'est pas le sien mais qu
est-ce qu d'audrey qui n'est pas le sien
et vous savez je pense que très vite on
passera à autre chose pour vous en tout
cas moi ce que je sais c'est que benoît
hamon quand il a été désigné il était à
15% il a fini à 6 aujourd'hui j'ai bien
vu qu'elle était à 7,8 bien allons-y
finir à 15%
je suis pas même plus j'espère même plus
quand je considère que l est dans une
dynamique et surtout une détermination
mais c'est à elle de dire quand et
comment elle annoncera son éventuelle
candidature
mais les choses s'organisent je peux
vous le dire et notamment je vous invite
à ce grand rassemblement qu'elle
organise à villeurbanne le 12 juillet
prochain où il y aura de nombreux élus
et et je sens qu'il ya une appétence
dans les élus socialistes et au travers
des élus au travers de l'électorat
finalement notre électorat est orphelin
depuis 2010 est bien souvent il fait
remobiliser pour les municipales il
n'accepte pas mobiliser parce que aux
européennes s'étaient pas un des
loteries était en tête il faut le dire
très simplement et là je pense que le
choix pouvait être critiquable et nous
avons aujourd'hui au travers des
départements des régions on le voit bien
une très grande stabilité voire même des
progressions parce que il ya département
qui malheureusement basculer à droite
mais même plus qui ont basculé à gauche
la réunion le la région l'arrivée dans
les autres mers la gauche a très
largement voilà donc le je pense que le
socle est bon pour une belle candidature
socialiste en du lait c'est forcément
des loups est ce que déjà le 12 juillet
elle doit dire clairement son envie
parce que jusqu'à maintenant ce n'est
pas très clair je prendrai toute ma part
c'est que je ne suis pas le porte parole
de daniel go
mais en tout cas je contribue avec bien
d'autres à ce que cette candidature
puisse devenir une évidence aujourd'hui
elle n'est pas une évidence il faut que
les une évidence laissons le temps au
temps vous savez c'est la fable de la
fontaine il faut pas partir trop vite
et puis à quel pas ce qu'est ce que par
exemple carole delga cayla présidente la
mieux élue en président socialiste de la
région occitanie plus quasiment 58% des
voix est-ce qu'elle elle ne peut pas
conquérir au nom des couleurs des
socialistes à d'abord félicitations à
carole des gars qui effectivement a fait
le meilleur score et a été clair sur ces
valeurs
d'ailleurs vous remarquerez que tous nos
candidats n'ont pas mis leur drapeau
dans la poche ils ont tous été voilà élu
en tant que socialiste bien sûr clair ça
veut dire n'a pas failli ans avec les
écologistes et sa nouvelle
donc je n'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit qu'elle
dès le début dès le premier tour
elle n'a pas caché son drapeau et ça
c'est très important parce que même
quand vous voulez que je vaux drapeau on
sait qui vous êtes un bon que donc il
faut faut y aller
carole delga fait partie d'éventuelles
solutions ne s'est jamais déclarée sûre
sur le sujet moi je sais qu anne hidalgo
et voilà une solution qui semble de plus
en plus avancé elle faisait partie de la
solution historiquement et maintenant
elle commence peut-être à devenir la
solution et carole delga j'en suis
convaincu sera dans cette dynamique
comme d'autres présidents de région on a
un personnel politique permettez moi
l'expression qui aujourd'hui est
nombreux
n'oubliez pas par exemple sur les 42
villes de plus de 100 mille habitants
quinze ou seize sont aujourd'hui des
villes dirigées par des socialistes
le ps qu'on disait moribond les
socialistes notre famille politique ce
notre sensibilité ne l'est pas et les
élections l'ont démontré une dernière
question sur les régionales vous dites
les candidats socialistes ont été clairs
sur la valeur quand je manuel valls et
jean paul huchon appelle à voter valérie
pécresse en ile de france ils sont
claires sur leur valeur en tout cas ils
ont fait de leur boussole et ça ça vous
fait du tort à oui biensur l électorat
je suis triste je suis triste parce tout
d'abord ce que je connais tant jean paul
huchon que comme del vals wells est mon
patron et que je respecte pour qui j'ai
de l'amitié mai
une fille n'arrive plus à comprendre sur
un plan politique moi je le regrette
on vous n'y a pas deux gauches
irréconciliables la france insoumise de
le faire il doit faire partie de la
gauche au même titre que les écologistes
de la france a soumis c'est jean luc
mélenchon s'est pas tellement les
militants et les électeurs d'information
miss et jean luc mélenchon donc et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les choses
commencent à se clarifier les sondages
aussi jeunes que l'on baisse de sondage
en sondage il n'est pas la solution pour
la gauche de gouvernement je le dis très
très simplement
moi je respecte dans la gauche a
toujours une sensibilité d'extrême
gauche très structuré moi je respecte
jean luc mélenchon je respecte ses amis
j'ai pas toujours sentiment qui
elle-même respect de sa part au travers
de ses sorties parfois virulentes à
l'égard d' des sociaux démocrates et les
socialistes en particulier donc c'est
comme ça c'est sa manière d'exister mais
finalement ça ne trompe plus personne
personne ne croit aujourd'hui en tout
cas par quelques militants acharnés que
jean luc mélenchon peut devenir
président de la république en 2022 trail
on va en quelques mois passés au reste
de l'actualité emmanuel macron y était
chez vous hier dans le nord à douai
emmanuel macron il veut tourner la page
des régionales il veut mettre l'accent
sur la relance sur l'économie et il
n'exclut pas de relancer la réforme des
retraites on parle en tout cas les échos
le journal les échos parlent d'un report
de l'âge de départ à 64 ans qu'est ce
que vous en pensez être sain c'est un
joueur mauger macron joueurs mais ils
jouent avec la terre et de la france et
les français
c'était pas possible vireux quand on
voit la répartition de l'effort dans
cette crise l'état fait beaucoup
d'efforts mais qui se finira par être
payés par tous les français donc la
répartition de l'effort a été injuste
pendant cette crise jamais les grandes
fortunes n'ont été aussi riche et
finalement il ya une indécence tous les
rapports montrent que voilà quelques
centaines de familles françaises et bien
se sont enrichis pendant cette crise
alors que des millions d'autres se sont
appauvris les inégalités se sont
creusées alors c'est vrai qu'on a tenu
le choc y compris pour des petits
salariés avec le chômage partiel est
malgré tout quand vous perdez 16% du
pouvoir d'achat ou vous à progresser et
aujourd'hui dit eh bien on va régler ce
problème
on demande encore plus d'efforts aux
salariés
français les plus modestes je trouve ça
scandaleux c'est là aussi c'est indécent
de pouvoir évoquer une telle solution à
la quelques mois de la fin de du
quinquennat ce n'est pas possible
et si monsieur mac ont fait ça il mettra
le pays à feu et à sang
tu prends une dernière question
commencer l'interview en disant on ne
change pas une équipe qui perd vous
pensiez à la france après france 3
suisse où vous regardez match bah oui
j'ai regardé le match était j'étais allé
sur les pignons gg des menus le débris
comme ancien ministre des sports c'est
qu'on peut pas demander toujours à une
équipe de gagner voilà c est fait comme
ça il ya des moments où on gagnait les
moments de mon père
et donc il faut pas en faire un drame
national
l'équipe de france pourra se ressaisir à
la coupe du monde de 2022
gg une fin en tout cas aux préliminaires
j'ai eu une pensée pour qu'elles mba
pkoi parce que voilà c'est le dixième le
dixième tueur but
je crois que sa première série de tirs
au buts dans sa carrière et voilà il le
loupe ce tir avec un excellent gardien
quand même un disons le pur pour la
confédération helvétique
je le regrette mais déception oui mais
c'est la loi du sport purement et
simplement on gagne on perd c'est
rarement autrement quand on fait du
sport et on va regarder la une de ouest
france ce sont les bleus 1 dans
l'édition nationale les bleus à la une
de ouest france euros 2021 les bleus
éliminés par la suisse dans l'édition
nationale et puis c'est du vélo du
cyclisme sur la une de l'édition de
rennes puisque le peloton arrive en
ille-et-vilaine aujourd'hui quatrième et
dernier jour en bretagne vous allez
regarder
patrick kanner la chance et c'est un peu
le tour de france je serai en séance sur
le téléphone du traitement si vous avez
caméra dans le dos et dont on peut voir
ce que vous regardez un ok merci merci
[Musique]